this film production logo is so ballsy I
straight-up have no idea what company
it's for but good job on being ballsy
enough to not include your name mystery
production company this horse is wild
enough to make me wonder why he was ever
put on carriage pulling duty in the
first place that Sherlock had a head
start on that or is he actually
parkouring faster than the cops in the
horse and buggy using the roof building
where they're having a black magic
sacrifice of a young woman isn't locked
first point for tack Robert Downey jr.
is a handsome fun charismatic lead actor
who cannot do an English accent to save
his life is it too much to ask that
Sherlock Holmes actually be British I
don't know how good a deductive
reasoning is but he wouldn't been able
to guess that that guy had a floating
rib are we sure this girl doesn't
deserve to be sacrificed what I mean
we're sure this girl doesn't deserve to
be sacrificed so what gives with the
sacrificing discount the end of mummy
days this guy seems to be late to the
ceremony he also didn't get the memo
that they all didn't have to wear the
hooded robes doctor after all forcing
some dialogue so we all know this is
Watson which is totally necessary
because anyone watching this movie
couldn't have seen the movie poster or
trailer or DVD cover that shows Jude Law
as Doctor Watson
here's a Holmes and Watson that can
physically and literally kick some ass
and you didn't know how badly you wanted
them until you got them all right two
guys who are clearly outnumbered take
out all the henchmen cliche some of
these villains have something more than
clubs to protect their crime scene with
surely a lord could spring for a gun or
lots of guns right all the tortures blow
out like not magic Sherlock Holmes roll
credits how did you see that because I
was looking for it
Sherlock doesn't say because even though
it's clear reflects light and is still
visible to the naked eye was that just a
sharpened piece of glass that
miraculously didn't break for as long as
he was hiding it was he hiding it in his
sleeve if so how did it not stick him in
the arm there are more effective ways to
vanquish your enemies beyond insurance
of class damn mark Strong can't catch a
break
brilliant actor keeps getting villain
roles in forgettable action films poor
bastard he seemed surprised
be ready for him to say you seem
surprised a lot it's good that they
didn't have cell phones in the 1800s
because that guy would totally be gotten
fired but not prosecuted for kicking
that dude in the face you don't mind
yeah sure totally under arrest but you
can walk around without anyone holding
on to you to make sure you don't try to
escape if I was the editor of this
newspaper I would have just admitted the
picture of the asshole covering his face
altogether
thank you to captain Phillips man Tom
Hanks it's just a transformative actor
and seemingly so humbled it takes us a
small role but I'm sure his own spin-off
film was in the works from the very
beginning perhaps a nice cup of tea
Watson at least is sufficiently English
there are far more bullet holes here
than there were shots fired was he just
trashing his apartment in shooting at
the wall for three weeks and it took
Watson to come in and mildly suggest a
new case for him to perk up and start
looking the absentee landlady I feel
like shooting a gun at the wall would
give her good cause to a victim so he
probably shouldn't be mocking her what
Michael Vick would be doing if you were
alive in this time period
there's nothing Ben turist full here out
there Holmes perfectly sums up
introversion I think the people who made
this film have confused Holmes deductive
reasoning skills with people watching
this waiter is really bold stealing the
silverware in front of everyone instead
of in a more secret place this guy's
such a stickler for details how is he
not noticing the waiter who looks like
he's straight out of Friday Night Lights
stealing the silverware I have a pile of
detective novels at home over to Colin's
PO no Arthur Conan Doyle he's good I
didn't blade fight his house to you
what is he proving by showing her
something he already knows ah I stopped
from the boxing match now I can infer
that she's a bit of a gambler you can
also infer that he likes boxing or likes
to watch juice what'd he do to each
other in this movie Robert Downey jr.
plays British Tony Stark
at which point you broke off the
engagement mattone doing Clues at the
prospect
Sherlock's jealousy of this woman really
so irrational that he would imagine the
worst-case scenario rather than the most
realistic and innocent one he not only
arrived early but he also ordered before
everyone else to Holmes has always been
brusque and eccentric but this version
is just an asshole I used to be made fun
of if I just opened poem slap someone in
a fight well I appreciate the way this
movie uses boxing to show off Holmes
superior mind the idea that a reclusive
agoraphobic investigator would regularly
participate in chaotic grimy street
fights is beyond what my suspension of
disbelief can bear at the end of the
movie we find out that he's actually
just a figment of Edward Norton's
imagination why is no one else paying
attention to her she's far better dress
than anyone else and pretty much the
only woman in the room
a Victorian era Irish
would come to a screeching halt as soon
as she walked in the door if Sherlock
can mentally map out every move of a
physical fight why was it a more evenly
matched bow before Adler showed up this
movie has an even bleaker view on London
then the Muppets Christmas Carol does
and that's saying something we find out
later that Lord Blackwood paid this guy
off to fake like he's gagging on the
ground and I'm sending this because we
didn't get to see how that exchange went
down was this guy just corrupted and
easily swayed by money or was he a
really good cop that just never felt
like police work was his true calling
and that dreams of being an actor he saw
this as a big opportunity to see if you
really had what it takes
if Lord Blackwood is really as dangerous
as they all think and this master
manipulator why did they put him in a
jail cell in close proximity with these
very impressionable possibly mentally
ill prisoners or all they're solitary
confinement cells taken up by other
well-to-do black magic criminal
masterminds I using musicals ooh I don't
think you can call this musical theatre
I however think you can call it you not
knowing how to play the violin you a
black woods last request and they're
just gonna honor it gives it he's a lord
with power yes but he's also a
scandalous murder and there's no reason
to cater to him do all average rich
citizens get one last dying illegal wish
confused about the geography here
Holmes's shop is in Northeast London and
they're headed to Pentonville prison
which is also in North London but it
looks like based on this shot they
crossed over London Bridge heading
southbound when there's absolutely no
reason to do that that's like driving
from Texas to Mexico to get to Oklahoma
am i overthinking this someone's got to
Watson punches him square in the nose
without leaving a scratch or bruise or
even a moment of what man that can hurt
you're such a dick was picketing more of
an art form back then all of these
people really know how to make some good
looking Restoration Hardware caliber
signs this movie perpetuates the
stereotype that British people have bad
deep that's racist that's a very clean
and starched collar for someone who's
been in prison per month
they added some supernatural swoopy
sound when he clearly just got up
quickly like a normal person
you know sentenced to death for the
practice of black magic Victorian London
was pretty backwards but not that
backwards where they were they also
later in the film we find out that he
had some kind of harness to keep him
from being choked and we're supposed to
believe that all the people who got a
close look at him after this moment
including Watson didn't notice an
apparatus around his torso that would
have kept him alive during a hanging now
that's a little overboard on the
emasculating symbolism huh looks like
Sherlock keeps his David Crosby disguise
handy just in case
Irene he works for a floating top hat no
one has told Sherlock that he needs a
bow to play the violin
after falling through that shed he
sustains no injury that's the isn't the
Irene he knew already a street criminal
hasn't she remained that all huh what
does this mean
he found his bow nice little Vicky can
play the violin and has smashed open
from the inside
Holmes tells us at the end of the movie
that this slab was broken and put back
together with a mild adhesive that would
be washed away by the rain which doesn't
explain how it didn't just cave in to
the tomb shutting him inside or all the
cops in 18th century London just
five-year-olds who use the Zoltar speaks
machine so they could weasel their way
into the police force that's the only
logical thing I can come up with to
explain why all these cops are scared
was to do anything concerning Blackwood
now you get down there and you bring
that coughing up yeah the inspector
didn't have what seemed to be a very
effective pep talk with his officers
before Holmes and Watson geoduck Holmes
is so good he is apparently allowed to
get away with tampering with evidence
see when the dead walk the living will
fill these coffee's is he insinuating
that all the living people will be dead
coz if we're all dead what's to keep us
from walking around with those who were
previously dead unless the dead are
gonna come and get all the alive people
and put them in the comments regardless
this guy has some explaining to do a
supernatural explanation to this case is
theoretically possible no it's not the
man is like a drunk why is it always
assumed the worse with these two eh well
isn't that convenient if Watson is
supposed to be this brilliant doctor
then has developed considerable
deductive powers of his own how could he
not see right through this gypsy woman
making very general predictions about
his future playing dice on a
checkerboard but still using the
checkers in some way because this game
the ginger midget or the same Parisian
perfume irene must bathe in perfumed not
there would be no way he could smell it
over the ammonium sulfate phosphorus
formaldehyde and the rotting carcasses
of rats in the other room Riordan was
working with Blackwood Corson's Holmes
and I said of course he was at the same
time arsonists burn along super-huge
pugilist just in case they encounter
private detectives on the scene they're
supposed to burn down
holy did someone use the remains of
Frank Zappa to construct a Frankenstein
monster a Frank Zappa and Stine monster
now would be a great time for Holmes to
deduce an exact ten-second way to take
this guy down cymbal blowing away the
smoke of a weapon that just did
something cool cliche Holmes must have
legs made of steel or the roads in 18th
century London were made entirely of
crash pads this is the third time we've
seen where you should have broken
something
why doesn't Holmes have any of his
previously demonstrated premonition
vision regarding this fight discount
become whole survived all this these
guys somehow got arrested over that the
last scene and now I wish I'd paid more
attention because I didn't think they
did anything arrest worthy but I'm also
high on cocaine so pretty sure there
would be a separate woman's jail right
right
I wonder what bills set up for the two
guys who destroyed the shipping yard to
which the bobbum says may I push in your
school and we're borrowing scenes from
what about Bob
the only Baker to see such an French
glaze on their lives holds a sense of
smell is on a superhero level if Robert
Downey jr. was an already Iron Man I
would submit that Sherlock Holmes should
be an Avenger
you might be thinking amazing since it
smell doesn't make a good superhero and
I would respond by saying remember
Hawkeye he gets to be a top tier Avenger
and all he can do is shoot a bow and
arrow
this guy didn't even put up the
slightest fight Holmes basically said
they have similar eyes and ears and Sir
Thomas tells everyone his super secret
life story I want you to find him and
stop him before he does to defeat this
very powerful dark sorcerer they will
send a detective who doesn't believe in
magic movie repurposes old-timey footage
from lame is and from Shanghai Knights
movie and female leave both
intentionally tease my crotch not cool
even for a saucy sexy international
thief and genius that has a lot of eye
makeup for an 1890s woman come with me
um I already I mean oh yeah for sure so
hones the amazing deductive detective
didn't notice the lazily hidden syringe
nor could he smell which he put in the
wine with his superhero nose to
reiterate we all know he is not using
magic to do all these things but they
never explain how he's able to blow out
all the candles at once I bet when Lord
Blackwood was a kid he never got invited
to birthday parties you know I have
watched this entire movie up until this
point without pausing beyond a little
bit of note-taking and I have no idea
what the fuck is going on I'm serious
I'm lost as hell why is Sir Thomas's
secret black magic room off of the
bathroom
I guess practicing black magic makes you
very dirty this satanic star is not
upside down which makes me think it's a
Bloods gang symbol as opposed to a
satanic thing the future ruled by us the
future ruled by rich white dudes I've
got good news the civil wars made them
weak true but that still happened about
25 years prior to these events for
comparison you know what happened 25
years ago in our real lifetime Germany's
reunification a lot happens in a quarter
century is what I'm saying gift fuck you
yep um no way the bad guy isn't super
dead right now what a contraption the
villain has gone full snidely whiplash
slaughter Lord black woods voice can
really carry with all that madness going
on
this German locks
in trouble this comment is coming from
the man who is yet to successfully pick
a walk throughout this entire film go to
the villain to consistently put Holmes
in Batman style escapable traps in three
based on the speed in which this
contraption is moving Holmes would have
been cut in half on one how none of them
got a 2x4 launched in the sternum is a
mystery sometimes when he can't figure
out a case a solution Holmes sits in
front of a wall full of scribbles and
plucks a violin it somehow helps don't
question it Holmes with a sound
analytical mind scribbles names and
other related nouns all over the wall
like a madman has no one ever taught him
the attaching pictures with string
technique thankfully this movie about
Sherlock Holmes master of all intuition
and logic turns into some kind of
mystical cult ghost death thing which is
the opposite of Awesome flashback
overload this Watson sash appears to be
offering no medical improvement
whatsoever sure does look nice though in
that I won the Spelling Bee kinda way
very distinctive those handmade shoes of
whose are they really distinctive Zappos
has a whole page on their website
dedicated to shoes that look just like
that maybe he started a trend in dress
shoes that has persisted over 150 years
no but I don't care much what you think
Holmes now possesses Blackwood's power
of non-directional speaking there isn't
any time to waste
Holmes reveals his location with the
quippy line that he could have avoided
and just jumped out of the window
eliminating the possibility of being
shot the three main characters take down
all 20 plus henchmen without the
slightest injury I think the chains they
are putting on the door should work just
fine I don't know if the group of
elderly British men in locking arms is
gonna help we are now witnessing the
longest 12 chimes in the history of Big
Ben Irene was running full force towards
what was very obviously the Lich maybe
she had her eyes closed because she's
scared of heights please don't
underestimate him Irene is just saying
and we need a plot for the next movie
that is a well-known stone that Irene is
stolen it's probably not a good idea to
wreak if tit as an engagement ring which
is the most shown off piece of jewelry
and diamond engagement rings didn't take
off for commoners until the 1930s anyway
a Victorian engagement ring would have
been a plain gold band I was trying to
introduce the madmen which of Blackwood
survived his execution so he decided to
test this while he was by himself if
suicide isn't in his repertoire then
idiotic experimentation definitely is
smella difficult the mobile see under
I know kung fu' singing of the
street-corner choir it's going home and
getting warm by the fire
remember remember the fifth of November
the gunpowder treason and plot